Hi guys, I'm Eric Voss and Marvel has surprised us with the first teaser trailer of Thor: Ragnarok
And for real I am super hyped for this movie
It looks like marvel is pivoting from Thor: the Dark World to tell a more colorful
Cosmic adventure in the vein of Guardians of the Galaxy and really what readers of the Thor comics always loved
And I think another big reason why this trailer is
So fun is that it includes a ton of little winks and easter eggs that remind us of other exciting superhero movie moments
so in this video
I'm going to break down all of that along with some theories and predictions
And I'm going to go super in-depth frame-by-frame leaving
No, infinity stone unturned and yeah
I said stone not gem from the comics because gem doesn't really work with the expression anyways, shut up. Let's get started
Now I know what you're thinking
How did this happen?
so the trailer opens with thor
Chained up lowered into this deep lava cavern Temple of Doom style and right away the trailer does kind of jokey pause on him
With this meta narration "now, I know what you're thinking
How did this happen?"
and this is interesting because it's not very common to see a
Superhero narrate his own movie like this in fact this moment kind of reminds me of that scene in deadpool where he also similarly
Explained to the audience. How we ended up so horizontal
"I think we can all agree that shit just went sideways
In the most colossal way" but this isn't the first time this has happened in the MCU either remember iron
Man 3 began with a similar voiceover from Tony stark "a famous man once said we create our own demons. I don't
I'm goona start again" and sure I don't know if thor's line here was recorded just for the trailer or if this line comes later
In the scene with like Hulk or Valkyrie or Loki or if it's all part of a framing device
The way it was an Iron Man 3 with Bruce Banner in that post-credit scene like maybe this time
It'll be Thor baring his soul putting Bruce to sleep or maybe it'll be Tony nodding off
We'll see either way since this is the third Thor movie
I think this narration a lot of other stuff in this trailer just wants to echo the third iron man movie also
Where is this place?
It's dark and fiery and those glowing rocks
Look kind of like faces like they could be the faces of the damned, so this is most likely Hel
in norse Mythology Hel is the opposite of Vahalla in Asgard and in the comics
It's ruled over by Hela the goddess of Death Cate Blanchett in this movie who looks
Awesome in this trailer so Hela is confined to her own world ruling over the dead
But she wants to expand her rule over the dead in Valhalla as well, and in this shot
It looks like she's breaking free from her world
We can see her torn clothes as she walks through the rift in space and let's move on to the second part of this shot
Well it's a long story
Okay, so huge moment here Hela freakin' catches Thor's hammer Mjolnir
And she destroys it so this surprise catch reminds me of that trailer moment in Captain America Civil war when the winter soldier
catches Cap's shield
Um noone is supposed to be able to do that
So yeah, it's a big deal for Thor to lose his hammer
And I'm guessing that this happens early in the movie because we never really see Mjolnir on him in any other shots and I
Think that this is another detail that connects Thor to the other avengers
Remember both the third Iron Man and the third Captain America movies both separated the heroes from their iconic weapons
Tony blew up all of his gear and chucked his Arc
reactor and cap left his scratched shield behind him at the end of Civil war and sure tony just ended up making new armor and
I'm certain that we'll see cap with the shield again and I'm predicting that Thor will end this movie with some version of his hammer
Maybe a new one modeled on the ultimate Thor comics like we saw in the infinity war concept art but I think these
Avengers losing their toys is an important lesson to learn like what Tony told Peter parker in the recent Spider-Man homecoming trailer
"but I'm Nothing without this suit" "if you're nothing without this suit then you shouldn't have it" now
It's looking like this movie will also reveal the sixth final infinity stone after the time stone was revealed in Dr.
Strange that just leaves the soul stone and some people had a theory that the soul stone was
Inside Mjolnir since it's kind of a magical
Instrument and only the vision could lift it maybe because he has the mind stone on his forehead now
I don't see an infinity stone anywhere in these shards maybe Hela grabbed it already or maybe it's somewhere else but more on that
Later also this fight looks like it's happening in an urban location
Maybe New York, and we know from set photos and the doctor strange post credit scene that Thor is going to be visiting Dr.
strange at his sanctum Sanctorum in New York City looking for his brother Loki and his father, Odin and if you look
Really closely at this wide shot. You can see Loki with thor in this alley
This scene was actually depicted in the concept art so I'm guessing that thor found his brother in New York
but Hela caught up to them or
Loki might have arranged this to trap thor but I have other thoughts on that theory later on and real quick
I just want to point out the look of this Marvel studios title card notice how it flies out at us
That's similar to the titles in the guardians of the Galaxy volume two trailers James gunn who directs those movies actually?
Tweeted that this trailer for thor Ragnarok might be the best Marvel studios trailer ever even besting his own trailers
But honestly considering that thor seems to be using a similar
Vibrant visual style to the guardians movies gunn's approval seems a bit more like excitement over his own positive
influence on the MCU right moving on
Asgard is dead
So in this section we hear this awesome music
It's immigrant song by Led zeppelin, and I honestly don't know how this song wasn't already used for a thor movie
it's kind of the perfect rock anthem for Norse Gods the lyrics are all about vikings dreaming of war and conquest with lines like
hammer of the Gods and Vahalla,I am coming
But the song also works in context for Hela who rules over hel and niflheim?
Which is a realm of primordial ice and cold or as led zeppelin puts it
And like the speaker in the song hela is kind of an immigrant
Invading this new land in order to conquer it and let's talk about hela here
She looks fierce with this insane antler headgear almost identical to Jack Kirby's
original design in the Marvel comic and the composition of the shot with the angles of her antlers
Contrasting sharply with the background makes hella look so sinister
and I just love the thought they put into the photography of this movie we also see hella as she arrives an
Asgard and proclaimed it dead
So this is connected to the title of the movie
Ragnarok in the Earlier thor Comics Ragnarok referred to the end of the universe in Norse Mythology
The destruction of valhalla and the death of all the gods
It's actually part of a cycle that repeats over and over with asgard being reborn
Afterward and lasting until the next ragnarok occurs now this isn't to be confused with the character Ragnarok
That was a cyborg clone of thor from the Marvel Civil war comics run, and that's not really part of this movie
So this is the event
Ragnarok and while it was something that we did see in the comics thor were actually found a way to end that cycle hellas assault
Here comes from a different part of the comics when she conspires with Loki to try to bring about Ragnarok
But she fails actually interesting thing about that comic thor has to fight without his hammer
Just like he does in this movie and this version of Hela gets a lot closer to full
Ragnarok torching asgard and this wall of fire now
I'm not sure if this close-up of thor in the fire it's from this battle exactly or if it's back in, New York
But this is pre haircut
so I'm guessing it's early in the film before he's exiled to the sakar which we see in this shot as
Thor flies out of a portal
So just to recap what I see is the timeline of these shots thor starts out in New York with doctor strange
And then he finds loki
and then gets jumped by Hela who chans him up and
Banishes him to Sakar leaving asgard more open to attack
And if that's the case that really only seems to cover the first part of the movie so there's so much about the story that
We still don't know which is kind of great alright Let's move on
So here we see thor on the planet sakar
Which is this scrap covered planet that love gladiatorial combat and yes
This is all from the planet Hulk comics which I'll talk about later
But this idea of thor getting taken in as a warrior slave seems like its borrowing from movies like mad Max Beyond thunderdome
Which like thor Ragnarok was the third installment of its series
And it was about a warrior who
Ends up in his shitty place forced to fight as a gladiator the character even goes from long hair to short hair and this person
Kidnapping Thor is valkyrie If he's played by Tessa Thompson valkyrie is a major character from the thor comics. She's also known as Brunhilde
She leads the valkyrie or which is a group of female warriors whom guide the souls of Slain heroes back to valhalla
But in this movie valkyrie has ended up on sakar gathering fighters for this gladiator combat, and these other shots might explain. Why?
valkyrie left her old job
You can see her here with her iconic cape from the comics riding her winged horse
Aragorn with the other valkyrie or leading an assault on Hella
Inhale and this looks like it could be part of that same sequence as that shot of hela
That was saw before and after hela tosses her sword
There's this quick shot showing valkyrie and her warriors falling to the ground
So I'm guessing that this was part of a flashback battle scene showing how this humiliating defeat
Led to her exiled to sakar like now
She's using her warriors seeking skills to bring back these poor souls
To fight to entertain the masses and as thor gets dragged in to get this involuntary haircut
You can see what looks like some other
Gladiators training and this guy is a trident some people are saying that that could be a reference to name or who?
Carries the trident of neptune or you know it's just a warrior with a trident you guys try to serve actually pretty great melee weapons
And before I move on there's this shot of valkyrie as she turns away from thor little guilty and she's carrying
What looks like a four pack of tall boys or something?
Maybe that's her bounty for bringing in thor, but this book of guilt implies that she still cares about her fellow asgardian
Maybe that means that she will be instrumental in helping him and hulk escape. Let's move on
What have you brought tell me
a condender
So this section introduces us to Jeff Goldblum as the grandmaster
He's the ruler of Sakare who arranges all these gladiator Matches in his colosseum
And check out these big furry things shimming on either side of Thor's so what the hell are they and my first?
Stupid thought was that these are just both the legs of a giant
Dancing whomp up from Empire strikes back like this video is both the marvel and Star Wars
Universe is so anything can happen but really these are probably just some goofy looking dancers on the Grand Master suite
and if you look closely at the background there are these red and blue figures on each side and this whole shot is
symmetrical and based on Thor's confused expression here
I'm wondering if he's under the influence of some drug that's causing in him to trip balls it would explain
Why he was so lethargic and passive as they dragged him in for that haircut
so really these bright colors and
goofy visuals are another element that makes or Ragnarok feel more true to the
Cosmic Adventurous spirit of the Thor comics and part of that same
Colourful marvel Phase 3 that the guardians of the Galaxy
movie belongs to and I think that's intentional because in the comics the grand master is one of the
Ageless elders of the universe along with the collector whom we saw in Guardians?
And I think that the relationship between these two characters is how thor ragnarok will tie into the events of the upcoming
Infinity Wars movie we also see this shot of heimdal
Fighting trading in his helmet for some awesome dreads now. I mentioned this before in a video that I did on Dr.
Strange but one popular theory is that heimdall
possesses the six infinity stone the soul stone now people think that this is partly because his name begins with an age and the
Locations of the other stones kind of Spell out the name thanos anyway
That's kind of a stretch, and I'm not totally buying it
but I do think that there definitely is something to on dolls ability to see souls wherever they are in the universe and
The orange glow in his eyes which might be connected to the soul stone
Which is supposed to have an orange color and some people have pointed to this round looking
Peace on his chest plate as possibly the soul stone. We'll see we also get our first look at Karl Urban as skurge the
Executioner now there's an interesting miserable detail about this shot of him that I'm going to point out but first quickly
I want to say that we love going super in-depth with all this marvel stuff and part of the reason that I'm able to do
That is by keeping up with all the marvel information using audible now audible offers a wide selection
Of audiobooks, and you can get a free audiobook with a 30 day trial at
audible.com/NEWROCKSTARS there's actually one audio book that I just finished called Marvel comics the Untold story by Sean
How it's about?
How marvel comics evolved to dominate so much of our culture and it explains a lot of why these movies are the way?
They are now audible is great for when you're commuting or working out or when you're getting a haircut
And you're just too awkward to make small talk swords with me, so you can turn your commutes
Or your awkward social interactions into something more with a free trial at audible.com
Slash new Rock Stars and start now ok back to skurge so in the comics scourge is kind of an anti villain like he kind
Of slow, and he always loses and his fights against thor but scourge is also known for wielding a double-bladed blood axe and here
He's firing two M-16 this could be a reference to one of the coolest things about this character
But may be kind of big spoilers, so if you're worried about that skip to this time so in thor issue
362 Skurge is on a suicide mission
Led by thor into hel to rescue Mortal souls held unjustly
By Ella and in order to escape they have to cross this narrow bridge called the oliver
Separating the two worlds and it climaxes with this dramatic redemption scene of skurge firing M-16 to hold the bridge
sacrificing his life while the others escape in the words
He stood alone a gala drew end up being that's powerful epitaph for the character
And I think this shot of scourge with a machine gun looks at least like a reference to this iconic moment, okay?
Let's move on to this next section
its main event time
So here we get one shot
that looks like it could be part of thor's and hulk's escape from Sakare and
Another look at Hella and battled asgard now wearing the antler headgear
Probably just seconds away from stabbing someone with it come on could have shown us that but we also get this
Mysterious shot of Loki as he flips his daggers now. We still don't really know for sure
What loki is up to in this movie?
But my best guess is that he was somehow instrumental in releasing hela from hel remember at the end of the Dark World Loki was
Impersonating Odin. I think that he might have been able to use that
Stolen authority to unleash her on asgard and to bring about Ragnarok also
Let's look at the shot a bit more closely that looks like a bridge
Maybe gala brew the bridge between worlds that I talked about before and that mountain this
Passage behind him could lead to the Rocky terrain of hel that we saw on the other shots also
There's this mob of people trying to push through
these
Might be souls of people trapped in hell trying to break free hopefully future trailers will give us a few more angles on this to
make some sense of it and these next shots bring us to the main event of this trailer the
Coloseum on sakare with these green smoke effects probably to celebrate the green crowd favorite and thor enters the arena
Looking very much to me like maximus from gladiator with this shorter hair, and yeah
I kind of want to see him throw that had doubts pole into the audience and scream like you're not entertained
and I'm really digging thor's helmet design here it kind of addresses the issue that bugged a lot of fans about the thor movies the
Fact that the movie thor never really wears the helmet from the comics and to be honest it was never really an issue with me
Like I never really cared for the wings on his helmet
But this helmet with the adjustable chin guard gives thor's head that classic shape while remaining
practical it actually kind of reminds me of
Catwoman and the Dark Knight Rises how her goggles flipped up to look like the classic cat ears? No no kind of cool alright?
Let's move on to this final awesome clip
We know each other He's a friend from work
Seriously, it's like Marvel read all of our minds and knew exactly what kind of movie
We wanted this to be everything about this is so perfect first notice Thor's
Shield here red and White stripes blue inner circle it kind of seems like he picked that out because it reminded him of caps shield
Also, it's so great to hear the grandmaster introduce the hulk this way
And I'm really liking how marvel is using these heroes comic book descriptions of the trailers can't you just be a friendly
Neighborhood Spider-Man and yeah hulk just looks fantastic. Here's the CGI is really well-rendered and notice his armor now
this is clearly taken from the planet hulk comic story line so a quick reminder in the comics hulk goes on a
Rampage that destroys most of Las Vegas so nick fury sends him on a space mission
Where he ends up on sakare fighting as this popular Gladiator warrior?
So neither Hulk's nor thor were present for the Marvel Civil war event which is also one of the reasons
Why they were left out of a civil war movie?
But now it seems like the plan is to bring thor into this planet Hulk, storyline
Which I think is brilliant because not only we we get to see an awesome rematch from the avengers will also probably get to see
Them work together as old work friends probably breaking free
We know each other
He's a friend from work and Thor's reaction here reminds me a lot of Drax's huge laugh in the guardians trailer
it's basically what we are all feeling in this moment and judging from the reaction the crowd and the Grand Master and
Even match is less preferable to hulk just smashing someone's brain in also
It's interesting that Loki is joining. The grand Master here in these very Jack Kirby inspired box seats again
It seems like Loki is playing a more nefarious role as if he's come to see his brother suffer, and maybe die
But judging from Loki's nervous glance to the Grand Master is probably remembering the last time he ran into hulk
And I think this side shot of the two friends charging at each other which by the way
I think the words going to get the first hit with that uppercut all this is meant to evoke
Another shot that ended a recent marvel trailer
so now we see what hulk and thor were doing while the rest of their friends were in a civil war they were in the
Middle of their own ok that's everything that I caught in this trailer and let me know what you think in the comments
What do you think Loki's plan will be where do you think the soul stone in and how will Dr.
Strange play into the story like I know that sorcerer supreme is in this movie too, and I was too overwhelmed
But if you like this video please hit like and subscribe to newrockstars we cover all kinds of Marvel stuff all
Super in-depth like this, so take a look around and if you really like this channel, you can contribute to us on Patreon big
Thanks to all of our current patrons you guys are awesome. Especially kelly dunn
You can hit me up on Twitter at Ea voss with any thoughts or theories you have about four Ragnarok or follow [the] new Rock
Stars on Twitter at new Rock Stars for updates on our videos alright. Thanks for watching bye